it'll be nice this morning to get
outside take your coffee break we'll be
in the low 80s by then nice skies except
that you can see a little bit of that
wildfire smoke and haze the air quality
advisory is still in place we'll go over
that in just a minute temperatures a
little above normal so first hour of
daybreak and the sun will be up here
shortly after 6 30. that's when we get
our coolest temperatures of the day so
this is the time if you want to exercise
outdoors or take a jog and bike ride or
take the dog out and do it right now
when it's cooler just it's more
comfortable but we do have some of that
wildfire smoke and haze lots of 70s
around the valley humidity just above 20
percent the air's dry so keep yourself
really hydrated get that water going
before
you're pumping the caffeine today 75 in
boulder city but we do have some nicer
60s in mesquite down to 60 at indian
springs mid 60s in prom and even 50s up
at caliani ely's off to a chilly start
again at 36 tonopah at 57. so the air
quality advisory issued yesterday
morning we had a lot more haze in the
sky yesterday at this hour than we do
today but we still have some and enough
to warrant that air quality advisory for
elevated smoke and haze and ozone too
because of the extra warm temperatures
smoke forecast just reinforces that as
we roll it you can see orange yellow and
boy once you get to purple that
indicates much denser smoke so we get
through today into saturday and early
sunday morning we're looking at midnight
now things start to finally lift out so
the lighter blue indicates better air
cleaner air and then over here is where
that smoke concentration is all the way
up to reno down through central
california that's where the wildfires
are staying dry in the west showers
through the northern plains and all that
flooding rain that's plagued the eastern
third of the country this week is
finally moving offshore but it's those
big fires in the sequoia national forest
that are pumping out all that wildfire
smoke this windy fire it grew more than
ten thousand acres in the last day and a
half so there's a lot of smoke out there
and we have a very light northerly flow
and that's what's bringing in that smoke
into southern nevada monsoon moisture
it's active it's been producing some
thunderstorms and we saw some get real
close to clark county yesterday but we
didn't get anything in the valley we
didn't really expect that we would 94
degrees today mostly sunny but still
that smoky haze around i think it's
going to last right into saturday too
with above normal temperatures just
barely above normal sunday now next week
we have a cooler system that's moving in
and that will bring a chance of mountain
showers wednesday breezy winds to the
valley with some clouds and 80's for a
couple of days i think that will feel
better mornings cooling off to the 60s